hello and welcome back to another dw
business special i'm christy platson in
berlin heath's been the topic of the
week here in europe and that's in every
sense of the word we are deep into the
summer season here in europe and
countries acros across the continent
were plagued this week by droughts heat
waves and wildfires
but that's not the only reason people
here are sweating the week kicked off
with news that russia's gazprom couldn't
guarantee gas flows through nordstrom
that nordstrom one would resume
following scheduled maintenance of the
pipeline it's a major supply route to
the eu and germany in particular
as temperatures hit 40 degrees celsius
and wildfires raged in spain and france
european leaders were putting sweaty
heads together to figure out how exactly
to keep homes warm and industry running
in the coming winter months
now there was a slight sigh of relief
thursday when gas did in fact start
flowing again through the pipeline
albeit at the same reduced rate as
before the repairs that is 60 percent
below full capacity russian president
vladimir putin said russia would fulfill
its commitments to supply natural gas to
europe but warned that flows via the
north stream pipeline could be curbed
soon if sanctions imposed over russia's
war in ukraine prevent additional
maintenance on its components so
tensions are also heating up and i have
two guests joining me to talk about this
uh today here in the studio i have vada
imran from the business desk joining me
thank you so much and um on the line we
have vasily astrov he is senior
economist at the vienna institute for
international economic studies thank you
both for joining me today
so i want to hop right into it residents
of the town of lubin in germany where
russian gas arrives from the nordstrom 1
pipeline are relieved that deliveries
have resumed but some remain skeptical
let's have a listen
it's great and has to stay that way
everyone has probably had some doubts
but we thought putin wouldn't make
everything worse
he has to become more reasonable
you can tell that people are quite
affected
they're all from here but what can you
do about
it if the russians turn off the tap we
will all be affected by it all of
germany
i think he'll turn off the gas again i
don't trust him
well people in germany are really
concerned about the country's supply and
with good reason
at this time last year the average rate
for one megawatt hour of gas in europe
was less than 22 euros for comparison
today it costs 166
euros
so warta
first question to you those are some
shocking figures we just took a look at
here
looking at germany specifically how are
households dealing with such high energy
costs now i mean have your energy bills
gone up i mean so i think it really
depends on where you stay with city
you're in how many people live in your
house how big your apartment is and i
think the gas bills they range for that
but one thing my research has showed to
me is that almost everyone is paying
double of what they were paying this
time last year in some cases it's even
more than that but we know for sure that
it's double in some cases i know a
friend of mine who actually lives in a
shared flat and he got a notice from his
landlord saying
that his rent prices are going to go up
soon because gas is included in that so
i think people are really really worried
yeah i mean understandably that's quite
a significant increase that you're
talking about here and obviously a lot
of people don't have the incomes to
anticipate that kind of cost i want to
take a question out to vasily looking at
this from the russian side of things
what has cutting gas supplies to europe
meant for russia is this hitting their
revenue in a significant way
well not really one thing is that yes
russia delivered less gas but the prices
are higher so the price um
high prices over compensated to some
extent the
cuts in in quantities that is one thing
and the second thing is that gas sales
are not as important to russia as oil
sales so oil sales are about three times
as important as
sales of natural gas and of course we
know that the oil prices are now very
high so actually russia is now flooded
with
export earnings so no for russia the
answer is definitely no
yeah that's a good point about the oil i
think especially from here in germany we
tend to lose perspective about that
because we're so focused on natural gas
another question tawarta here talking
again about uh these uh high prices how
exactly are households coping with them
i mean
do they just have this cash lying around
i can't imagine they do
i think um people have started to
internally in their own lifestyles
trying to like cut their dependence on
gas i think they hear a lot also from
politicians and leaders saying you
should take maybe shorter showers maybe
you should turn your lights off and not
take those things for granted that you
took before so i think people are really
taking that
um some of my friends and people in my
building have actually
put a cap on their gas so that they're
saving 300 to 400 euros per month by
just doing that so i think people are
actually looking into their own pockets
to finally realize this is hitting them
it's no more pumps anymore it's also
your households so by cap i assume
you're talking about a physical cap
there that curbs uh yeah yeah yeah
that's definitely something that'll be
interesting for germans going into the
winter months i'm sure so taking it back
to vazili now
looking at this from an economic point
of view we heard from those vox pops
that people are worried that russia
could shut off uh the gas but
economically how likely are they to shut
down nordstrom one completely this fall
or winter
economically there is absolutely no
reason no motivation for russia to
stop supplying via nordstrom one
and that is basically because if they do
this type of things they will further
undermine
the their credibility as a
supplier of natural gas to europe which
has already been shaken over the past
few months and that means that in the
longer run there will be more effort
towards
diversification of
gas supplies and overall energy supplies
away from russia so that means that
europe will become less dependent on
russia in the longer run and best is not
good
for russia
that will create additional problems for
russia so all in all economically there
is no reason for russia to do that but i
think economic reasons are not the most
important here because if
if it had been about the economy if
economic
motives had been uh at the forefront
then russia after all wouldn't have
started the war uh either so here i
think we really have to think about
political uh motivations and not
economic ones
yeah that's a really great point we
obviously uh putin's politics have
played a major role in this whole war
from the very beginning
well i mean uh moving a little bit
forward on this europe of course does
not want to be left out in the cold this
winter and this week the european union
told member states in fact to cut their
gas usage by 15
from august until march as an emergency
step
now the proposal is currently a
voluntary target but the european
commission could make it mandatory if
the bloc were to declare a substantial
substantial risk of severe gas shortages
eu states are trying to ensure storage
facilities are 80 full by november
they're currently around 65
full
now european commission president ursula
vonderland she didn't miss mince words
of what she thinks of the situation
let's have a listen
russia is blackmailing us
russia is using energy as a weapon and
therefore in any event whether it's a
partial
major cutoff of russian gas or total
cutoff of russian gas europe needs to be
ready putin
is trying to push us around this winter
and this he will dramatically fail
if we stick together and we'll get them
stronger out of this crisis than we went
into this crisis i'm deeply convinced
now vasily again to you you told us in a
recent interview that trade sanctions
wouldn't start biting russia until
quarter three quarter four we're getting
into quarter three now who is in the
stronger position now heading into the
colder months russia or the eu
uh russia is already in a recession or
has been in the recession uh starting
from april or since april that is a fact
whereas the eu is not
and this recession in russia will get
most probably only worse in autumn yes
when the trade sanctions uh western
trade sanctions start biting and the
full effect will be felt by the end of
the year
so that is a fact what will happen in
the eu as i said at the moment the eu is
still doing reasonably well of course
this may change
if there is a stop to russian gas
supplies the eu will most probably
slide into a recession but this depends
on the russian policies so
uh
at the moment i think what we can say is
that uh
if indeed there is a cutting supplies
that both
sides will suffer russia will be in a
recession and you will be in a recession
as well so it's a lose-lose situation
then
okay well that's a bit uh pessimistic
news but i mean let's talk for a second
about oil here this is another russian
fossil fuel that the block sanctioned at
the end of may it's one that we don't
talk about as much as gas
how has that been playing out those
sanctions against russian oil here in
the eu
i think it has been a big miscalculation
on the part of the eu and the west more
generally specifically the design uh how
these sanctions were imposed so
basically the eu
imposed an embargo starting from the end
of this year so from december for uh
crude oil and starting from february
2023 for russian oil products
that means that the physical uh volumes
that the quantity of oil will only stop
flowing uh to the eu starting from the
end of this year
but
what we already see what was immediately
observable once this decision was
announced by the eu once the embargo was
announced by the eu was the sharp
increase in prices and partly this high
level of oil prices that we observe
these days is partly the
the result of this decision to announce
and
an oil embargo with a time delay
so i think in that sense this decision
uh or the way it has been
constructed has been counterproductive
because at the moment it provides russia
with additional oil revenues with
additional
money for the russian government
and thank you for giving us some insight
into that situation now coming back to
this commission proposal to cut gas use
across the block by 15 percent for this
to become mandatory it would need the
backing of all eu
members ministers are planning to
discuss it next week but feelings are
mixed on this idea our correspondent
marina strauss in brussels has more on
this certain member states are not on
board we have to say that very clearly
for example hungary is a case that is
very special they have already said that
they don't want to export energy to
other eu countries because they
themselves are in an emergency situation
then we have countries like portugal
spain other eu countries which are not
very dependent on russian gas and they
say why should we limit our gas use our
gas demands
we want to keep our industries running
of course and this whole question of
solidarity is also a very difficult one
in the eu when it comes to energy
okay warda
listening to what marina just said there
can you give me a better idea of what
some of these differences are between
the member states i know germany is
particularly reliant on russian gas for
example maybe other countries aren't as
much or maybe we can talk about hungary
what can you tell me about this
i think it's all a question of reserves
it's about who has what right now and
who's willing to go far in order to get
it the thing about the question about
hungary is the fact that they are at
dangerously low levels of gas reserves
and so they feel the need to go out of
their way to secure the gas supply for
their country i mean
on this in the same way poland for
example is in a really good position has
secured 90 percent or more of what they
actually need and so question the
european unions or the european
commission's decision to cut down energy
gas consumption by 15 because they think
we need that to kind of keep our
businesses moving so i think when you
see that there's such a big disconnect
um within the eu you can kind of see
cracks of disagreement i think it's been
around for a while it's becoming obvious
now and i think we can see that member
states are starting to go their own way
kind of make their own deals i think
that's going to be interesting to see
how the eu actually can pull this off
yeah i imagine to some degree that this
is a bit of what uh putin was counting
on that that these cracks would would
widen as the months go on but can you
tell me even with all that in mind
is it realistic or how realistic
realistic is it that they could pull off
a 15 cut across the board well so the 15
cut is a proposal right now all the
member states have to agree to it
they're in conversation today we should
hear more about a decision next week
but realistically i think that i think
it's ambitious i think it's possible but
i also think that we must keep in mind
the current decisions the current
promises challenges kept by the german
government to phase out coal soon by
2030 they want to cut their greenhouse
gas emissions by 55
for that you got to be a bit more
careful about you know they've restarted
coal plants again so i i do hope that
it's possible to cut that dependence but
i would like to see what are the costs
or benefits for that sure yes what i'm
understanding from your point there is
that the eu has these commitments to get
off of fossil fuels that they um are in
some cases neglecting and so it remains
to be seen how much they can follow
through and that brings us very well to
our next point and a bit to coming back
where we started um all of this we were
talking about intense heat
here in europe
and i want to talk about where this
looming energy crisis that we've been
speaking about also comes together with
the global climate crisis
now the petersburg climate dialogue took
place in berlin this week germany's
foreign minister annalena belbach called
on the global community to step up its
efforts and take immediate action
against man-made global warming she
called it the biggest security problem
facing everyone on this earth here's
more from her
eight years left
to almost half global emission
that's the commitment we made in glasgow
but we also have to focus much more on
the climate impacts that we have failed
to avert
we owe this to the people around the
world
in the pacific islands in sahel
and in other regions who are already
suffering
and who already feel the impacts of the
current
climate crisis
well as a reminder there that the
effects of climate change are nothing
new to many parts of the globe even if
they're only just starting to bite here
in europe so i want to take the next
question back to vazili i'm hoping that
you can maybe tell me about russia's
stance on the green energy transition
obviously a country very reliant on
fossil fuels
when it comes to its economy does
breaking free from fossil fuels pose an
existential threat to russia
well russia is a bit different from
europe because uh for a long time um
green transition climate crisis were not
really recognized as existential threats
to russia it changed um over the past
few years basically once uh the
permafrost in the russian arctic region
started melting and there were lots of
problems with
you know pipes uh falling apart and so
on there were environmental disasters
this made the russian government change
its mind and now there is a strategy
a climate friendly strategy in russia
but of course it is by far not as
ambitious as the
environmental plans as the climate
policies of the eu now what uh what do
the
uh eu policies climate policies mean for
russia um of course uh if
really the eu manages to use more
renewable energy to use less
fossil fuels
a large part of which comes from russia
this is not good news for
for russia but it is not dramatic as
long as russia can reorient its
exports of oil and gas to other markets
to china to india
to other non-western countries
it is
it is reasonably easy to do in the case
of oil this is already being done so for
instance the
deliveries of russian oil to india
already
jumped 50 times
starting from a low basis for instance
with gas it is more problematic because
this requires appropriate infrastructure
at the moment
most russian pipelines gas pipelines run
westwards so around towards europe so
reorienting this gas flows to asia will
be much more difficult it will take a
lot of time but in the long run uh
probably it is not dramatic for russia
as long as other parts of the world are
lagging behind in the implementation of
green agenda behind the eu
well i want to talk about in the long
run here for a second i mean there's so
many issues that we're facing right now
that need to be solved as quickly as
possible it can be easy to only look at
things in the short term but looking
longer term 10 years 20 years longer if
you like
what would it mean for russia if europe
gets off of russian energy or if they
work with these other partners china
india as you're saying also especially
considering that there is global
pressure to move away from fossil fuels
which you just spoke about to some
degree
well here yeah uh here the the thing is
that on the one hand russia will
probably be able to reorient the large
part of it of its energy exports to
non
non-european markets china and so on
that is one thing
another thing is that this reliance on
the energy sector is a problem in itself
so as long as the energy sector
remains the backbone of the russian
economy
it is a problem for the development for
for the russian economic development for
its ambition to
to sustain catching up with the rich
economies that would mean that the
russian economy would
have to grow faster than the global
average and
in the current situation it looks like
the opposite will be the case so that
means that on a global scale the russian
economy will become
an even an ever smaller part of the
global economy so i think this is a
problem uh for russia that is a
structural problem this is nothing new
this excessive reliance reliance on the
energy sector how to solve this problem
you need to invest
and this investment needs to be um
needs to bring new technologies it needs
to
it needs to bring modernization of the
economy i think the current geopolitical
climate it will be more difficult for
russia and this uh
this increased
trade and cooperation with china for
instance will be able to have set the
disruption of economic ties with the
west only to some degree so it in the
long run
the prospects for russia are not very
good i would say
all right well just to round things off
here i want to go with a one final short
question to vada bringing it back here
to the heat we've been facing
in here in germany are people more
concerned about uh the hot temperatures
or are they more concerned about heating
their apartments this winter what's the
feeling on the ground everything they're
concerned about the heat they're
concerned about the heating they will
need in the future they're concerned
about everything and personally i feel
like this may give birth to more
grassroots movements for climate
literacy and i think that may be
important people may finally start to
change their lives for the
better all right well we'll have to
leave it there for now uh that's all we
have for you this week from our little
business desk but we'll be back with
another business special for you next
week i want to thank my guests vasily
astrov and vada imran for joining me
today thank you both
now for your viewers if you'd like more
please hit the like and subscribe button
i'd also encourage you to check out the
dw business series here on youtube
business beyond which takes a look at
business business phenomena shaping the
globe for me and the whole business team
here in berlin thank you so much for
watching until next time take care
you